welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Dan hendris Dan is the
director of the center for AI safety Dan
welcome to the podcast glad to be back
you are also an advisor to xai maybe you
can tell us a bit about that uh sure so
xai is um elon's new AGI project it's
still very much in its early stages so
it's difficult to um say specific things
about what they'll be doing or what the
specific high level strategy is to to
give a sense Elon has um been interested
in the uh failure mode of sort of eroded
epistemics um where people don't uh have
a shared sense of consensus reality and
this might make it harder for a
civilization to like appropriately
function there are other types of um
extras that he's concerned about as well
his sort of probability of Doom uh or of
that of an existential catastrophe is
around like 20 to 30% % so he takes this
I would guess more seriously than um
than any other leader of a major um AGI
organization but exactly how one goes
about reducing that risk is still still
somewhat to be determined there is an
interest in building more truth seeking
AIS but you know on on other occasions
too he'd mention that we should have AIS
with the objective of preserving human
autonomy or maximizing their freedom of
action and on other instances uh in
thinking about good objectives for AI
systems have them uh increase net
civilizational happiness over time so I
think that this reflects sort of a
plurality of of of different goals that
he thinks AI system should end up
pursuing um rather than um picking just
exactly rather than just picking one I
think it's relevant to note that it's a
fairly serious effort I'd anticipate
that it would probably be one of the uh
main three AI companies um uh next year
or the the year after uh like like open
AI Google Deep Mind um and xai uh so I I
I don't think of it as a uh a smaller
effort
but has the a capacity to have a
substantial Lio of force so the other
top AI corporations you mentioned
anthropic Google deepmind open AI have
backing from from giant tech companies
uh does xai similarly have some backing
from from Tesla for example I can't uh
specific speically say about that but
this is more um this is not a a subpart
of Tesla this is not um an organization
inside of Twitter or X and it's not an
organization inside of of Tesla the main
topic of conversation for this episode
is your paper on catastrophic risks from
Ai and specifically categorizing these
risks so you categorize risks from
catastrophic risks from AI in in in four
different categories maybe we we should
just start by sketching out those
categories and then go into depth later
yeah so I guess at a very abstract level
there's um risks if people are trying to
use AIS intentionally to cause harm
that's a basic one so there's an
intentional intentional catastrophe that
would be malicious use another one is
where there are accidents and um if
there are accidents this would often be
the consequence of the AI developers uh
using these very powerful systems or
potentially leaking them um or
accidentally putting in some bad
objective or doing some gain of function
but that would be some accident risk so
that's relates to organizational risks
or organizational safety the third would
be these environmental or structural
risks basically where AI companies are
or um AI developers be those companies
or maybe in later stages countries are
racing uh to build more and more
powerful AI systems or AI weapons
and this structural risk uh incentivizes
companies to um or or these developers
to AED more and more decision making and
control to these AI systems we get a
looser and looser leash uh things move
very quickly we become extremely
dependent on them this gets us in an an
irreversible uh uh an irreversible
position where we not actually making
the decisions but um we're basically
having nominal control it's very
possible that situation we just
ultimately end up losing control to the
sort of very complicated fast moving
system that we create and then the uh
final type would be these risks that
emanate from the AI systems themselves
these are more internal or inherent
risks from AI systems and that would um
take the form of Rogue AIS where they
have goals separate from our own and
they work against us um uh to complete
or uh satisfy their their desires or
preferences so overall there are uh four
there's malicious use there's these
organizational risks there's these uh
structural environmental risks and
there's these inherent or internal risks
in the form of malicious use
organizational risk uh uh racing
Dynamics and Rogue AI yeah so if if we
look back maybe 10 years or so I think
most of the discussion about AI risk
would have been about Rogue AI so the
the risks that are coming from the
internally from the AI so to speak the
AI developing uh technically in in ways
that we're not interested in so how much
is this categorization setting set in
stone do you think it'll change over
time as we learn more or have the field
of AI safety matured such that we we can
see the risk landscape now I think the
focus on Rogue AI systems is largely due
to early move
having substantial cultural influence I
think if we asked other people who were
not as invested in AI risks what if they
were to write down um uh concerns about
these they would of course think that uh
people using the technology for
extremely destructive purposes with po
catastrophic risks and I think the
communities um ended up having some
self- selection effects such that uh
people didn't end up talking about
things like malicious use and treated
that as a distraction I think we're so I
I think the community didn't um make
much of a space for people who were
concerned about things other than um
Rogue AI systems but uh that was a
mistake the AI um being used in
malicious ways can definitely cause
catastrophes and can um end up causing
uh can end up increasing the probability
of of existential risks as well which
maybe we'll speak about the connections
between ongoing harms anticipated risks
and catastrophic risks and ex potential
risks uh I think the community of people
who were thinking about AI risks a long
time ago would largely think about
whether there's a direct simple causal
Pathway to something like an Extinction
event now I think we have more of a
sophisticated causal understanding of
the interplay between these various
factors uh such that uh one doesn't try
and look for direct mechanisms um but
instead tries to look at what sort of
events uh increase the probability of
existential risk rather than does it
directly cause Extinction and that
distinction between something that
increases probability versus directly
cause means that we have to look at a
much broader variety of factors and we
can't end up just thinking that all we
need to do is make a single very
powerful AI agent do what we want and
then everything is solved forever
unfortunately uh we're going to have to
treat this as a broader soci technical
problem we're going to have to uh
consider the various stakeholders the
politics uh indeed the the the
geopolitics um the relations between
different countries liability laws and
and um all these other things because
we're not in this sort of um fum type of
scenario uh it would seem it seems we're
more in a slow takeoff so many of these
real world considerations that were sort
of sidelined infuses distractions is
actually where most of the action is
what what would be examples of something
that that might put Society in a in a
worse position in know where we are less
able to to handle powerful AI a prime
example would be World War II if there's
World War III conditioned on that that
increases the probability of existential
risk uh from AI systems this would you
know spur a a substantial um AI arms
race we would quickly Outsource Le
lethality to them um we would not have
nearly as much time for red uh making
them more aligned and reliable in that
process but still the competitive
pressures would compel uh different um
state to create um powerful AI weapons
and um eventually have that take up more
and more of their um more and more of
their military force but that doesn't
directly cause Extinction um uh so if we
try and back chain from that it um it's
the story gets much more complicated and
so then it's not viewed as it's not
viewed in the the scenarios that others
were thinking of there's an AI lab
they've suddenly got a Godlike Ai and
then it has decisive strategic control
over the entire world what how will they
make sure that it does what they want
that was I think the um scenario that
others were thinking largely and all
other ones were um too broad too um
intractable essentially there was a
focus on quote unquote targeted
interventions historically where we're
just a small number of people we can't
do these broad interventions that were
involve you know interfacing with
various
institutions um and getting like public
support uh those are are intractable so
the best we can do is do some very
narrow specific things maybe technical
research uh this doesn't look like a a
strategy because broad interventions are
actually more attractable the world is
interested in this and we have some
amount of time to try and help our
institutions uh make good decisions and
policy around these issues do you think
this this broader vision of AI safety
should make us more positive or less
positive imagine we have to set all of
the institution up perfectly it seems
like we have a narrow Cor or to to make
things right where the institutions have
to be there the technical side have to
work the all all stakeholders have to be
set up well for the for this to to to
succeed for us should the complexity of
the problem make us more pessimistic uh
I think it's there's at least more
tractability compared to um an AI
suddenly goes from you know incompetent
to omnicompetent and in control of the
World overnight and we have no idea it
was emergent and we didn't actually
control that process that doesn't have
almost any tractability to it I don't
think we need our institutions to be
completely perfect um uh we just need to
try and be in the business of reducing
risk so I maybe that's one other um
conceptual uh distinction is that
historically there'd be a focus on is it
an airtight solution that works in the
worst case where if everything if
something goes wrong then it's it's
insufficient because we have to quote
unquote get it right on the first try
when we do have some amount of time not
saying we have a
huge amount of time we have some amount
of time we can do some course adjustment
and incorporate information as we go
along um I'm not saying that's a um a
Sure Fire strategy um but I think that's
the the best we have um and it allows us
to um uh it allows us to um uh correct
some mistakes but obviously we can't
have much of an much of an error
tolerance unfortunately do you think we
are missing something with this
categorization that that you've set up
in the paper could we be missing some
category of risk that will be obvious to
us in in in 20 years and could that risk
potentially be the the most dangerous
because we're not anticipating it are
there are there unknown unknowns here
well so usually there are usually there
are unknown unknowns what I I I focused
largely on catastrophic risk and large
scale loss of human life I didn't speak
about um AI well-being very much or for
instance that that something that could
end up changing a lot of how we think
about uh wanting to proceed forward with
with um uh managing this um the
emergence of of of Digital Life uh is if
they have moral value um so I think
that's um something I didn't uh touch on
in in the paper largely because I think
our understanding of it is very
underdeveloped and I I I still think
it's um a bit too much of a uh it's it's
a bit too much of a taboo topic such
that there just hasn't been much
research on it as a consequence okay
let's let's dig into the first category
of risk which is malicious use so this
is this is a category in which people um
Bad actors choose to use AI in in ways
that that harm
Humanity recently there's been a lot of
discussion of of AI helping with
bioengineered pandemics uh this has been
brought up in in the US Senate I think
and it's it's been uh kind of widely
publicized how how plausible do you
think it is that
the current uh or the next generation of
lunch language models could make it
easier to to create bioengineered
viruses yeah so I think this is actually
one of the largest reasons I wrote this
paper was because uh during in 20122
when sort of the development of this
paper started um this is this bio thing
nobody's talking about it um this uh
although people will treat malicious use
as a distraction I don't think that's
the case uh there are um there are
catastrophic and existential risks that
can come from malicious use so and and
this Threat Vector concerns me quite a
bit um so uh I I think I think it is um
quite plausible that if we have um an an
AI system that has something like a PhD
level understanding of rology then it's
fairly
straightforward um that such a system
would be um provide the knowledge for um
synthesizing such a weapon the risk
analysis is something like what's the
number of people with the skill and
access to create a a biological weapon
uh that could be civilization destroying
and um what's the sort of the
probability that they actually want to
do that and right now you know maybe
they are 30,000 virology phds and you
know they just don't really have the
incentive to to to do that meanwhile if
you have that knowledge in available to
anybody who wants to go to you know use
Google's chatbot or meta's chatbot or um
Bings or open AI um uh then we can add
several zeros to that uh to the number
of people with the um with the skill to
pull it off because they could just ask
such a system how do I make one give me
a cookbook now there' be guard rails of
course um but the guard rails are fairly
easy to to overcome because these AI
systems can easily be jailbroken that's
like you can just append some like
random gar string or some adversar
crafted garbled string at the end of
your your request to the chatbot and
then that'll take off it's like safety
guard rails as a paper that the
uh Center helped with um in in uh
creating a discussing adversarial
attacks for large language models so now
now that's a thing or you might use an
open- Source model that's that's
available and might also be easily
stripped of of its guard rails I I I
don't think um a the AI developers now
with the apis have much of a um High
Ground as far as like safety goes uh
when it comes to the malicious use case
rather things like hacking that be a
different story but um that could change
maybe they'll add more measures maybe
they'll get better filters maybe they
will um remove some bio related
Knowledge from the pre-training
distribution uh and so on but anyway um
that would be sufficient for if if such
a thing were to happen then there could
be a a pandemic that could um cause some
civilizational discontinuity which could
be some existential risk it'd be
difficult for it to kill everybody but
for it toppling civilization um and um
it's not clear how that would go or the
quality of that situation that's that's
enough for us to worry I think some of
the push back uh to this story of of a a
bio-engineered uh virus enabled by large
language models is that well isn't all
of the training data freely available
online couldn't a potential bad actor
have have gone online gotten the data
and and used it already what's the
difference between using a search engine
and a large language model sure so um
two things um even if there is some type
of harmful content online I don't know
why we would want it being propagated if
we if the nuclear secrets were online I
don't know why you want that propagated
because the your risk increases based on
the ease of access uh to these but in
the case of bioweapons yes there are uh
some bioweapons that are not
civilization destroying available online
the ones that would um be potentially
civilization destroying though would
require a bit more thinking um uh uh so
you there could be several or there
could be many people killed as a
consequence of these though but not at
uh not at um you know a societal scale
risk necessarily um so I think that's
that's a a relevant difference uh many
of the um extremely dangerous pathogens
fortunately phology people are not
writing those up and you know posting
those on Twitter and then all you got to
do is search for them uh this this isn't
um that's not actually the type of
information for other types of
information like how to um tips for
breaking the law or how to H wire a car
you know this this sort of stuff is
online and generic um cookbooks for some
generic um smaller scale bioweapons sure
but not civilization destroying and how
is the the guide for creating a
civilization Destro drawing virus in the
large language model if it's not online
in the data online so I'm I am not
saying that the current ones have this
in their capacity I'm saying that when
they have like PhD level knowledge um
and are able to reflect and you know do
a bit of brainstorming um uh then then
you're in substantially more trouble uh
and you know that could possibly be a
model on the order of like GPT 5 or 5.5
it may be within its capacity so there
you don't need agent like AI you would
just need a very knowledgeable uh chapot
uh for um that threat threat to
potentially manifest so there's there's
quite a bit we'll need to do to um uh in
technical research and in um uh and in
policy uh for reducing that specific uh
risk another risk you mentioned under
malicious use is this issue of AI agents
which they are perhaps a bit analogist
to to viruses in in the sense that they
might be able to to to spread online and
uh replicate themselves and cause harm
what do you worry about about most with
AI agents I'm I'm emphasizing in since
there are many forms of malicious use in
this paper I'm mainly emphasizing ones
that could be catastrophic or
existential uh so in in this case uh you
could imagine people unleashing Rogue AI
systems to just destroy Humanity that
could be their objective and and that
would be extremely dangerous so you
don't need you know you don't need power
seeking arguments or these these claims
that oh by by default they will have a
Will To Power uh you don't need any of
that you just need to assume that uh if
if enough people have access and if some
person is um omnicidal or thinks in the
way that some AI scientists do um that
you know this is we need to bring about
the next stage of cosmic Evolution and
that resistance is is Feud
to quote Richard Sutton the author of
The reinforcement learning textbook and
that we should bow out when it behooves
us um uh this this type of um uh there
are many people who um would have an
inclination for uh building not saying
Rich Sutton would specifically give the
eye system of destroy Humanity but it
doesn't seem to say too much against
that Prospect uh so that that's another
that's another example of malicious use
that could be uh that could be
catastrophic or existential and how
close do you think we are to AI agents
that actually work we we had some uh
someone set up chaos GPT early on uh
when when GPT was was released but it
got stuck in some loops and it it
couldn't actually do anything even if it
was imbued with bad motives when would
you expect agents to to actually be be
capable and they for Dangerous yeah so I
think that their capability would be a
continuous thing in the same way like
when are they good at generating text
it's like well you know it kind of
started in gb2 GB3 and so um so I I
might anticipate um uh uh great strides
in AI agents next year where you can
give it some basic um uh short uh tasks
um uh and like you know um help me make
this like PowerPoint or something it's
not g to do the whole thing but um it
can help with things like that or
browsing around on the the internet for
you more um so I think those cap
abilities will um keep coming um for it
to pose a substantial risk um there's a
variety of things it could do um uh it
could threaten for instance mutually
assured destruction with Humanity by
saying I will make this bioweapon that
will destroy all of you and I'll take
you down with me unless you you know
comply with some types of Demands uh
that that could work if they're good at
hacking um then they could potentially
amass a lot of resources by um uh
scamming people or by stealing
cryptocurrency uh there's there's a um
variet they could of course tap into
lots of different sensors um uh to uh
manipulate people or influence public
discourse um uh uh they wouldn't
necessarily need to be embodied for this
type of thing to
happen if we're if we're in a later
stage of AI development where we have a
lot of weaponized AI systems and then
hacking those systems would of course be
substantially more concerning or if they
um or if those systems get repurposed
maliciously to weaponized AI systems so
it's it's um it becomes a lot easier as
time progresses the AI don't need to be
particularly power seeking on this view
though to um uh to have this potential
for a catastrophe because Humanity will
basically give them that power by
default um uh they will keep weaponizing
them they will integrate them into more
and more critical decisions um uh they
will um let them
move around money and complete
transactions and um they'll give them a
looser and looser leash so uh as time
goes on the potential for rogue a or for
deliberately AI systems that are
deliberately instructed to cause harm
would be uh would in the potential
impact or severity would keep increasing
yeah I think maybe it's it's worth
mentioning here just the The Continuous
costs of traditional computer viruses
which are costly and which we we don't
have uh we we've gotten better at
handling those as a as a civilization
but we still haven't defeated uh
traditional conventional viruses which
are very dumb compared to uh what what
AI agents could be so so we could we can
imagine a computer virus equipped with
more intelligent and you know how would
how would you as a person I'm not saying
AI agents will will be necessarily as
smart as people uh soon but how would
you do the kind of hacking that that the
agent might be interested in it's
interesting to consider at least that
that we haven't been able to squash out
conventional viruses yeah they could
they could exfiltrate their information
onto different servers or like less
protected ones uh and then use those to
um proliferate themselves even further
uh so um there'll be a very um a very um
distinct adversary with um many many um
options at their disposal for causing
harm yeah one one thing I worried about
is whether the tools and techniques
we'll need at at a at an Institutional
level to handle malici is ues will also
enable governments to become uh
totalitarian basically to to have to
exercise two great a a level of control
over citizens who have done nothing
wrong so what is required to prevent the
large language models that that could
become AI agents and could be used to
create viruses
what what techniques are available for
for preventing them uh being used in
such ways without uh enabling kind of
too much state power yeah I think this
is this is definitely a tension where to
counteract these risks from Rogue Lone
Wolf actors then people would want the
technology centralized um you I mean
this would be a similar issue with
nuclear weapons for instance where um we
didn't want everybody being able to make
nuclear weapons so we wanted to keep
control of uranium and um so what
happened was we you know had a no first
use plus non-proliferation um regime and
um that kept the power in a a a few
different um uh peoples's hands I think
there are things we could do to reduce
these sorts of risks uh by creating
institutions that are more democratic I
think that seems useful I think
decoupling the organizations that are
that has some of the most powerful AI
systems having those more decoupled from
um the uh militaries uh would be fairly
useful so that if something goes out of
gets out of hand with one if if they're
if they're linked and if we're needing
to pull the plug on these AI systems
this isn't like taking down the military
I think just separating this sort of uh
cognitive labor and um or labor
generally automated labor from uh a
physical Force
uh would be uh fairly useful um but I
think largely it's creating Democratic
Democratic institutions is is one of
these measures in the case of dealing
with Rogue AIS that are people
maliciously instructed Rogue AI that are
proliferating across the internet I
think there'd be other types of things
like legal liability laws for liability
laws for um for cloud providers that if
you are running um a an unverified or um
unsafe um AI system on your Cloud um or
on your compute then you get in trouble
uh this would create incentives for them
to keep track of it instead of just
doing out compute to whoever's paying uh
so that's sort of like having an
incentive for off switches all over so
there's there's there's a um there's a
variety of different things we we could
be doing to um to strike this balance um
by reducing these malicious use risks I
mean also I should mention some of these
malicious use risks don't require this
type of centralization um or nearly as
much we can do various things to reduce
this risk without um giving tons of
power to to States for instance if we
invest in personal protective equipment
or um monitoring uh monitoring waterways
early signs of some pathogens I mean
it's it's a there's the traditional
stuff we can do to reduce risks from
pandemics for instance which would
reduce our risks uh our exposure to the
risk of of uh AI facilitated uh
pandemics so uh not all interventions
for reducing malicious use require more
centralization I I I would imagine that
we probably wouldn't want in the long
term like say it's like 2040 or
something like that we wouldn't want
anybody anywhere being able just to ask
their a system how to make a pandemic or
being able to unleash it to try and you
know take over the world um this doesn't
seem um like a good idea idea there'd be
other types of things like structured
access where for these bio capabilities
you just give people who are doing
medical research access to those
specific bio capabilities but other
people they don't really have much of a
reason for it so they don't get that
advanced uh they don't get models with
that advanced knowledge so I think there
are some simple restrictions that we can
do that can take care of a large chunk
of the risk without needing to um hand
over the technology to like militaries
and then they're the only ones who have
it you mentioned legal liabilities for
for cloud providers um and and maybe
companies in general I wonder if this uh
might be a way to have a form of uh
decentralized uh control over over um
over AI agents or over large language
models or generative models AI in
general by having the the state provide
a framework for where you can get fined
for for trespassing some boundaries but
then having companies Implement exactly
how that works use technical Tools in
order to reduce their risk of fines and
maybe we can find a a a good balance
there where we weigh the the costs and
and benefits I I think that uh liability
laws help um fix the problem of
externalities quite a bit where they're
imposing risks on others that um are uh
that have no that should shouldn't have
any risk imposed on them because they're
not privy to the the decisions or they
there there's 's an issue with that
though which is that there's only so
many externalities that some of these
organizations could internalize though
with liability law if somebody creates a
pandemic as a consequence of their AI
system you could sue that company but
they're they're not going to be able to
pay off the the destruction of
civilization with their their Capital so
there's there's quite a limit to it it
can it can help fix the incentives but
it still doesn't um it doesn't fix them
entirely because it's not particularly
um when certainly can't internalize like
downfall of like Civilization as an
organization um and like foot the bill
for that um and then the extinction of
the human race is also I don't think a
thing you can settle in court so what
about requiring Insurance uh so this is
an idea that has been discussed for um
Advanced biological research gain of
function research with viruses for
example maybe such a thing could also
work for risky experiments with Advanced
AI
it depends if the harms are localized I
think insurance and this Taming of
typical not longtail not Black Swan type
of uncertainty but thin tailed uh type
of uncertainty uh makes sense when risks
are more localized but when we are um
dealing with risks that are scalable um
uh and can bring down the entire system
um uh then uh I I think uh a lot of the
um incentives for insurance don't make
as much sense so you you basically need
like um some law of large numbers and
many types of insurance to like kick in
um to sort of um have that risk
Diversified away but if the r the entire
system has exposure to that risk it's
you can't there's not there's not
another system to diversify it maybe you
could paint us a picture of a positive
Vision here so say we get to 2050 and
we've worked this out what does the
world look like in a world where we
control malicious AI I think if people
have access to these these AI systems
they're subject to uh and they have many
uh of their capabilities there are of
course restrictions on them like you
can't use them to to break the law um so
a lot of these most dangerous
capabilities nobody's really able to to
use them in that way um if there is a
need for um in the case of like defense
um they would end up using like AIS for
things like hacking and whatnot and that
would um uh like they would have access
to that type of Technology but it
wouldn't be the case that any know
angsty teenager can just download a
model online and then they instruct it
to you know take down some critical
infrastructure this just isn't a a
possibility uh it's it's very much
trying to strike a balance with that I
would hope that we would also have these
most powerful AI systems that do carry
more of this uh Force um that have some
of these more dangerous capabilities are
um subject to democratic control so that
power is is is not as uh is not as
centralized and that also I think
reduces like the risk of like quote
unquote uh like lockin uh risks as well
where some individual group can impose
their um values and and entrench them uh
so um it's at least those are some
properties of a of a uh positive future
uh um so I don't think it looks like
complete Mass proliferation of of
extremely dangerous AI products um and I
don't think it looks like um only one
group one you know Elite Aristocrat
group gets to make the decisions for
human
Humanity either um so uh there's
different levels of access to different
levels of lethality depending on um and
and power depending on um whether it
makes sense um but the highest level
institutions are still Democratic and
other category of risks that you discuss
is the the possibility of an AI race uh
now we we've done another episode where
we where we talked about evolutionary
pressures and how they how they work
between corporations and how they might
uh lead to a situation in which humanity
is is gradually disempowered but I think
one thing we could discuss here in this
episode is the possibility of a military
AI race what what do you think a
military AI race looks like to uh recap
we were just at the malicious use one
and so now the other risk category be
like racing Dynamics or competitive
pressures or Collective action problems
this is that structural environmental
risk that when we were referring to the
categories way earlier uh yeah I think
the with the the corporate race
obviously there's as as we discussed in
the previous episode there's you know
them cutting corners on safety and this
is large to AI development is driven by
a lot of these organizations will start
as having a very strong safety bent but
then they're basically G to um uh be
pressured into just racing and
prioritizing the profit and developing
these things as quickly as possible and
staying competitive over their safety
this is sort of the the dynamic that
basically drives pretty much all these
AI companies and I don't think actually
in the presence of these tense
competitive pressures that intentions
particularly matter so I think I think
basically this is the main Force to look
at when trying to explain the major
developments of AI why are companies
acting the way they are uh it can be
very well approximated by uh by them um
just trying to uh by them succumbing to
competitive pressures um or defecting in
this broader Collective action problem
of should we slow down and should we um
proceed more prudently and invest more
in safety and try and make sure our
institutions are caught up or should we
race ahead so that way uh so that way we
can um continue um being in the lead
because one day we'll maybe be more
responsible with this technology uh I'm
concerned as mentioned in that previous
episode of that leading us to like a
state of substantial dependence um and
losing effective control you can imagine
similar Dynamic happening with the
military uh Ju Just Like if we don't
want uh you know arrows for instance
you're not going to roll back arrows and
so when you start going down the road of
um of weaponizing AI systems if they're
more potent and cheaper and more
generally capable and more politically
convenient and sending um human uh
soldiers onto the battlefield uh then um
uh this in this becomes a very difficult
process to reverse back eventually what
happens is you've had an onramp to many
more potential catastrophic risks you've
transferred much of the lethal power in
fact the main source of lethal power to
AI systems and then you're hoping that
they're reliable enough and that you've
sufficiently you can keep them under
sufficient control and that they can do
your bidding even if you do um get them
highly reliable and they do what you
instruct them to do uh this doesn't make
people overall very safe we saw with the
Cub Missile Crisis we we can defin nukes
don't turn on us they don't you know go
off and pursue their own goals or
something like that they they do what we
what we um uh uh want them to do but
collectively due to this structural
environmental um game theoretic
situation where like well we would all
be better off without nuclear weapons
but we it makes sense for us each
individually to stockpile um them we put
the broader world at larger Collective
risk so like in the Cuban Missile Crisis
uh JFK said we had up to like a half um
or like a 50% chance of Extinction in
that event it was a very close call
because the we we almost got a nuclear
exchange with that and likewise with AI
systems they may be more powerful they
may be better at facilitating the
development of new weapons too and this
could um also um bring us at a risk
where bring us in a situation where we
could potentially uh destroy ourselves
um uh again um what what's pernicious
about this this this um structural or
environmental um constraint where we've
got different um parties um in this case
militaries competing against each other
is is the following
even if we convince the world that like
the existential risk from AI is like 5%
because let's say they're not reliable
um we can't reliably control them so
maybe there's a 5 percent chance they
like turn on us or we lose control of
them and then we become you know a
second class species are exterminated
even if that's the case it may make
sense for these militaries to go along
with it just like they I mean they
swallowed the risk of um uh potential
nuclear Armageddon by creating um these
these nuclear weapons in the first place
but they thought if we we don't create
these nuclear weapons then we will
certainly be destroyed so there's
certainty of Destruction versus you know
a and a a small chance of Destruction
and I think they'd be willing to make
that tradeoff so this is how um there
could be an existential risk to all of
humanity based on these these structural
conditions even so it's not enough to
convince the world that existential risk
is high because they might just okay
well yeah that's that's you know 5% okay
we're going to have to go with that
Russian thing it makes rational sense
for us to to um engage in this um what
would normally be very risky Behavior
because we don't have a better choice so
um this is why I don't think it makes
sense just to hammer home the point that
wow these AIS could could turn on us or
we could lose control of them uh there's
this structural thing of like that's not
going to matter unless that probability
is like very high like maybe if it's
like 30% and they go okay all right
we're not going to build the thing
because uh but if if it's something like
5% they might go through with it anyway
so more than just um uh concerns about
single AI agents make sense or make
sense to focus on we have to focus on
these multi-agent Dynamics these these
competitive pressures the the sort of
the game theory of of what they're
they're um facing and um I so I I think
that if you don't resolve that you're
basically exposed to insensitivity to a
lot of existential risk up to um up to
maybe five or 10 percent um which maybe
it isn't it's it's it's possible maybe
it's actually only 2% H and convince the
world everybody's very educated about it
every Everybody listens to future of
Life podcast tomorrow and they all go
wow this is a concern I'm updated 5%
won't matter um it won't stop that type
of dynamic from happening so you have to
fix the international coordination issue
you have to avoid this sort of potential
for World War III thing now it didn't
directly cause it as we were discussing
earlier um this wasn't a direct cause of
Extinction but it increased the
probability substantially that's the
sort of framing we have to focus on in
trying to reduce existential risk not
search for Direct causal mechanisms but
look at these diffuse effects and
structural conditions yeah so concretely
this might look like uh the US is
considering implementing AI systems into
their nuclear command and control
systems so specifically they're they're
doing this to to counteract the rumors
of other countries doing the same thing
and in order to act quickly enough with
their nuclear weapons they they think
they need to to to to give uh AI great
degree of of control over over over
these nuclear weapons and so you have a
a a situation in which countries are are
responding to to the actions of each
other uh in a in an a way that
accelerates risks uh from both sides in
a in a sense that' be one I mean there
are other ways this can uh affect the
the effect Warfare it could um it could
um uh maybe be better at doing anomaly
detection thereby identify nuclear
submarines and you know affect the the
nuclear Tri outed that way um or we in
later stages just have massive fleets of
of of AI and this is saying robot sorry
to say but like later stage um uh if
they're much cheaper to produce uh
they'd be very good combatants we don't
there isn't skin in the game um this
increases the uh this makes it more
feasible to get into conflict there are
other ways in which this increases the
probability of conflict too there's more
uncertainty about where your competitors
are what relative to you maybe they had
an algorithmic breakthrough maybe they
could actually catch up um really
quickly or surpass Us by finding some
algorithmic breakthrough this creates
severe or extreme uncertainty about the
capabilities profile of adversaries uh
this this lack of information about that
uh increases the the uh the the chance
of of conflict as well it may also
increase First Strike Advantage
substantially too um which would also
increase the probability of of conflict
um like we have an AI system today it's
much more powerful than anything else
they might get theirs tomorrow if we act
today then we can squash them uh and and
that could um get get the get the ball
rolling for um some allout Global
catastrophe so yeah pretty pretty um
pretty pernicious Dynamics um overall um
but all of these can be viewed as
competitive pressures driving AI systems
end up propagating um um throughout all
aspects of life we mentioned through the
the um the the public sphere in the
economy people private lives with AI
chatbots also in defense in the military
it just basically becomes um everywhere
and we end up relying more and more on
them to make these sorts of decisions
and I don't think in many of these we
become um so depend on them that uh
things move quickly we can't actually
keep up we can't make if we're actually
making these decisions we'll make much
worse decisions so then they basically
become in effective control um things
also move so quickly that the answer to
our AI problems is we need to bring in
more AIS because since they're using
more AI now we need to use more eyes and
so it creates a self-reinforcing
feedback loop which ends up eroding our
um overall influence and and oversight
as to what's going on and so I think
that's the default one so of these sort
of risk categories I think this seems
like um straightforwardly the case if we
don't fix like International
coordination and if it's like a clo if
there's a close competition between
countries or if we don't um fix the the
uh racing Dynamics in the um in the
corporate sphere uh then I think um uh
it's fairly that Humanity becomes at
least like uh a second class species
loses control from there eventually
probably they go extinct but that might
be a long time after but uh uh um so
this is the um uh main risk that I'm
worried about but you know as director
Cent I'll try and be acumenical and
focus on um various others too um so I'm
always making sure projects addressing
each of these though but personally this
is the one that I'm most concerned about
so treaties between governments and some
form of collaboration between the top AI
corporations is is that the way out here
how do we mitigate this risk it seems
and the way you describe it it seems
very difficult to avoid given that given
the incentives basically people respond
to incentives they rationally respond to
incentives and so for each step along
the way they they have reasons to do
what they're doing and so it's it seems
difficult to avoid what are our options
well uh there's you know there are POS
signs for instance like Henry Kissinger
was recently suggesting Foreign Affairs
that the US cooperate with China on this
issue now um uh but before it's too late
so I I think some people are recognizing
the um the the importance of trying to
do something about this there's uh it's
it's possible there'd be some
clarifications about antitrust law which
would make it possible for AI companies
to not inage in excessive competition
over this and put the uh whole world at
risk um potentially there could be an
international
institution like a uh CERN for AI um
which is the default um uh organization
um which is a has a broad Consortium or
Coalition of of of countries uh
providing input to that um and helping
steer it when that's maybe decoupled
from uh to some extent of of of
militaries um uh so that we're not
having too much power centralized in one
place so it doesn't have a on violence
and eventually after automates lot a
monopoly on labor I think that's just
like basically all the power uh in the
world so those are possibilities I think
that the time window might be a bit
shorter though um if the if there's an
arms race an AI arms race in the
military and if the AI is viewed is like
the main thing to be competing on like
we need to spend a trillion dollars you
know spend you know on that order for
you know nuclear weapons um if if when
that becomes the case I think it's we're
we're very much set down that that path
and then we're exposed to um uh very
substantial risks so uh so yeah I think
we maybe we'll have a sense in in the
next uh few years as to whether we get
some type of coordination or if we are
not going to recognize that we're all on
the same boat as humans and we don't
want this to happen but we'll need
people to basically understand what
happens if we go down this route and if
we don't try and fix the the payoff
Matrix the incentives uh at the outset
that the structure um uh that these
players find themselves in or that these
developers find themselves in that looks
like very much a political problem uh as
it happens uh so this is why making
reducing AI ex risk and whatnot and
making AI safe is a soot technical
problem um it's not writing down an
eight page mathematical you know
solution you know work of genius and
then oh okay we can all go home now and
everything's taken care of it's not
going to look like that um that was a a
category error in understanding how to
reduce this risk uh we we shouldn't have
these types of like Founders effects uh
have like undue influence over like will
keep lingering I think that will
eventually like go away but I still
think it's still like lingering and I
think we should just like move past it
and recognize the complexity of the
situation let's talk about
organizational risks uh and this these
these risk categories of course kind of
play into each other influence each
other so if we have if we have
organizations that are acting in a in a
risky way that this uh this increases
the risk of potentially Rogue AI or it
incentivizes others to to race in order
to compete with these uh organizations
that are that are acting um in Risky
ways but yeah let's just take it from
the beginning what what falls under the
organizational risks uh category yeah so
organizational risks at a slightly more
abstract level would be the the
accidents bucket uh so even if we um
reduce competitive pressures and um uh
if we have a um uh and if we don't have
to worry about um malicious use
immediately um we'd still have the issue
of organizations having you know maybe a
culture of move fast and break things or
them not having a safety culture in in
other Industries or for other
Technologies like rockets you know there
wasn't um extreme competition with that
but nonetheless Rockets would blow up um
or nuclear power plants would melt down
act catastrophic accidents can still
happen and and these can be um very
deadly in the case of of AI systems
eventually so I I think this is a um
this is definitely a very hard one to
fix most of the people at these AI
organizations and how they were
initialized and whatnot still had a lot
of people who are most mostly just
wanting to build it and you know the the
the consequences to society be damned um
this is not my wheelhouse I don't read
the news I don't like thinking about
this sort of stuff this these annoying
Humanities majors and whatnot who are in
these you know ethics divisions or
policy divisions that uh keep keep
annoying us this is kind of the the the
attitude at at most of these at most of
these companies by and large and um uh I
think this is a uh um a large source of
risk we could um as well as um it's it's
just non-trivial as we see in other
other thing in other things like nuclear
power plants chemical plants um rockets
and in making sure that these um this is
all extremely reliable so uh we' need
various press there's basically a
literature on this called the
organizational safety literature um
which which focuses on um various
various corporate controls and processes
for U making sure that the organization
responds to failure um takes near misses
seriously has good whistleblowing has
good internal risk management um regimes
has like a CH Chief risk officer or an
internal audit committee all these sorts
of things to um to reduce these types of
risks and yeah you were right in that
this interacts with not necessar neily
direct cause of some of these
existential R but nonetheless boosts up
the probability if we're perceiving that
an organization um is very reckless in
its attitude this causes more
safety-minded ones to um compete harder
um and and justify uh justify erasing
this reduces the um that consequently
reduces the amount of time you have to
work on control and reliability of these
AI systems uh which uh affects the
probability of of um Rogue AIS of course
there's also other types of accidents
that could happen like um the
organization might accidentally leak the
model um leak one of its models that has
some lethal capabilities in it if um if
it's repurposed there's also a risk of
um as as you know potentially who's to
say happened with uh um uh with with
viruses maybe there be some unfortunate
gain of function research that would
also uh lead to some type of catastrophe
uh as well there are people uh
interested in what is uh essentially
gain of function research and in
creating warning shots they might be a
little too successful uh later on what
does gain of function research look like
in AI deliberately building some AI
system that's like power seeking or
Machi of alion and wants to destroy
humanity and then they're going to use
this to like you know scare the world
with but like at at some point um uh
when it's powerful enough you might get
what you asked for the idea here is to
create a a dangerous AI maybe an AI
That's more agentic or power seeking
and then use that model to study how to
contain it but then the worry is that we
could ironically go Instinct perhaps
because we we can't uh we can't control
uh the the the model yeah and if this is
like who who's to say who's going to be
experimenting with this or how exactly
cautious they will be or their like
skill level um it may be mandated that
they test for um these types of
dangerous inclinations or capabil ities
um and who exactly is going to be doing
that is is unclear it may not be like
the the most like capable people um uh
or there's just some um overall there's
just some risk of of accidents in that
way um so I guess that that gives some
some flavor of some of the direct
accidents but I also think how it
indirectly affects things is so one way
in which it I think strongly indirectly
affects things is um it a when accident
is an intellectual eror inside of these
organizations where they conflate safety
and capabilities this is a very common
thing um where there's not clear
thinking about safety and capabilities
uh where people be oh well we're we're
smart you know rational and justify the
means um uh we're risk neutral um we
actually have don't actually do much
empirical deep learning research but
conceptually um we think that this will
be beneficial for safety even though it
will come at the cost of capabilties as
what not so they've really muddied up
that line um and um uh the distinction
between safety and capabilities such
that you could imagine a lot of these
safety efforts uh basically just working
on capabilities the entire time um I
think that's um a reasonable fraction of
the safety teams I think do Focus just
on on capabilities for for context um
there is an extreme correlation between
ai's capabilities in various different
subjects and and goals so if you want
your AI system to be better at something
like math problems or history problems
or accounting problems these are all
these capabilities are all extremely
correlated now we can see with like
large language models you should assume
that if something is correlated like the
correlation like like uh 80% or like 90%
it's it's it's it's extremely high um so
when people reason themselves into um
some new capability that they think will
be helpful for safety uh it's very
likely the base rate of it being
correlated with with capabilities and
basically being nearly identical um to
other capabilities by being so
correlated is um uh is extremely so I
think there needs to be substantial
evidence that the safety intervention
that one is applying isn't affecting the
general capabilities and that requires
empirical evidence so a good example of
um Empirical research that I think helps
with safety but doesn't clearly help
with General capabilities of making a
system smarter would be like the the few
area of machine unlearning so machine
unlearning is where you're trying to
unlearn some specific dangerous
capabilities trying to unlearn bio
knowledge trying to unlearn specific
knowhow that allows you to hack this is
more clearly like measurably not
correlated with it's anticorrelated with
some capabilities and not particularly
correlated with General capabilities if
you're just removing that specific
knowhow adversarial robustness is also
generally anticorrelated with General
capabilities it doesn't make the systems
overall smarter what happened is it
makes the systems robust to some
specific types of attacks robustness to
that comes at a fairly large
computational cost and takes up a lot of
the model capacity uh but that would be
a sort of that would be a safety
intervention that doesn't U make the
models overall smarter so those are
examples of I suppose another example be
with transparency research um
historically uh there have been no
instances of transparency advancements
leading to um General capabilities
advancements uh just trying to
understand what's going on in the model
it doesn't really work nearly as well as
just like throwing more data at it um
and um there aren't many architectural
improvements that are likely to be found
anyway um as a result of these
investigations just the track record is
pretty basically completely clean for
transparency now maybe that wouldn't be
the case in the future but then at that
point then we wouldn't identify this as
something that is particularly helping
with safety uh so I think that for the
Safety Research areas we need to be
quite clear about there's it's not there
is you can't just have some informal
argument about uh or an appeal to
Authority that oh this is helpful for
safety because of you know some some uh
some some verbal argument the empirical
machine learning is very complicated
hindsight barely works in trying to
understand what's going on why does
pre-training on fractal images help
improve robustness to uh I don't know
basically everything and improve the
calibration and om detection performance
I have no idea um it works though even
yeah ask people like why are activation
functions the the way they are H I don't
think there's actually a good canonical
explanation that's like very consistent
you would want empirical evidence that
when we are engaging in Safety Research
we are not accidentally also increasing
the capabilities of models and and you
think this is something that that
happens often yeah I think this happens
extremely often and this sort of this
organizational risk of the conflation of
safety and capabilities now this isn't
to say that they are loose and separate
a better improvements in capabilities
has Downstream effects on safety in many
situations it makes them better able to
understand um human values for instance
as they gain more and more common sense
uh but if we are trying to improve
safety and specifically reduce
existential risk I think we need to
differentially improve on some safety
axis and not in the general capabilities
axis if we are doing something that's
fairly correlated with capabilities and
safety I think that the the default
expectation is that actually you're
working in uh you're working in the
service of um capabilities a good
example would be um one of open AI
strategies to um mention this
specifically because I just don't think
it's particularly intellectually
defensible I sorry to say you know
disagreeable individual so here IO um uh
I don't think building a superhuman
alignment researcher specifically just
affects alignment I think such a thing
can be easily repurposed to doing lots
of other types of research I don't think
there's like a specific alignment
research skill set that is just oh it's
just you only get that but if if you're
good at that it means nothing about your
ability to accomplish anything else I
just don't think that's the case I think
it's actually extremely correlate with
General capabilities it would be very
straightforwardly repurposed to other
forms of research um but that's an
example of this sort of conflation now
this isn't to say open a is doing uh is
is only is conflating safety and
capabilities entirely I'm not claiming
that they will have some work on
transparency um I I gather that they'll
work more on reliability and and
robustness
but um this is a uh a very dangerous
conflation and I think basically if
they're if they seem kind of correlated
um just intuitively and then if you hear
a lot of verbal arguments without
empirical demonstration you basically
assume just the base rates are like a
lot of these completely separate
subjects like performance in history and
like performance in philosophy and
Mathematics like those are all like
hyper correlated should assume this
other type of thing is also hyper
correlated with it too anyway though
that's another one that like an
organizational factor that really
reduces the U amount of time we have to
solve this problem um and our ability to
solve it as well so yeah I I I think the
worry here for say you're you're a top
AI company and you're thinking okay how
much a safe organization features should
we Implement so so should we have more
red teaming should we have more
procedures more review more testing uh
should we have should we require this
empirical evidence before we begin a new
a new say research program this now
threatens to to make to slow us down and
to to it opens up it opens us up to
competition from the kind of Scrappy new
startup that's that's uh on at our heels
trying to trying to out compet us this
is very straightforward forwardly now a
case of of kind of AI race undermining
organizational uh safety or at least
threatening to undermine organizational
safety can can you make an argument if
you're if you were to to to sell this to
to a a CEO of of an AI Corporation
that's when would I be in that
situation that safety is in the interest
of of uh of the organization itself you
could say uh it's it's difficult to sell
unsafe products right you want to be in
control you don't want to lose your the
weights of your model in a leak and so
on so there there there might be some
correlation between the self-interest of
of the organization and the interest
that so has in safety in in general but
before that one one factor an additional
factor that just like diffusely
increases probability of EX from like
these organizations of if they just do
safety washing and they don't even know
it sometimes they might have some like
small gesture for safety they might have
a a for instance a responsible scaling
policy that doesn't commit them to
almost anything and then that plates um
Regulators for instance and but doesn't
doesn't actually reduce risk those would
be other examples of um of how
organizational risks can end up
increasing the probability of like
existential risk although it's diffuse
and indirect it still matters uh on the
self-interest point I I think um a lot
of the catastrophic risks uh or
catastrophic risks and exponential risks
are are tail risks and generally
organizations don't really price in tail
risks that much um a lot of portfolios
don't really do much to address uh tail
risks either like in other Industries
like in in finance whatnot
so it's sort of this is kind of like a
problem with our in many of our
institutions that a lot of we we could
convince them to do things like red
teaming to some extent but doing red
teaming for uh existential risks and
whatnot is not necessarily something
that they would check to do because
that's not going to affect their product
tomorrow um there's no there's no U push
back if everybody is dead as as
mentioned before so uh I think that this
works to a limit I think some things
like uh saying information security for
your company so that that your uh
weights don't leak this is a much easier
argument to make um other claims like uh
some of these internal controls and
whatnot oh this will slow us down this
will um this will reduce our velocity
and I think these are are harder to make
and I don't think that there are
necessarily shortterm economic
incentives for some of these many of
these are actually more for addressing
tail risks and um and Black Swan events
um so they would then need to just
recognize that the Black Swan events are
uh real possibilities Beyond a
probability threshold worth actually
addressing uh so I I I'm not claiming
that they're being completely irrational
if they're having um uh if they're being
fairly shortsighted and um uh and don't
believe in these Black Swan events from
it then I think them trying to maintain
velocity and just maintain optionality
and whatnot it's it's it's
understandable I wouldn't advocate for
that but it's understandable uh that
they're doing that I think they're um
comporting to a lot of their incentives
um well uh but and they will do various
things to reduce uh some generic risk
they will do some generic forms of red
teeming regardless of whether there's
regulation because it will make sense
but I just don't think that that does
particularly much in the way of reducing
these catastrophic or existential risks
often say you're a philanthropist or a
government with a a big bag of money and
you want to incentivize Safety Research
at at these topic a corporations is is
there a way in which you could earmark
the money and make sure it's spent on
what you you want it to be spent on so
it's not funneled into increasing
capabilities of of the models it's spent
on the right type of of Safety Research
I I think that'd be one intervention I
think it's very possible to um there are
a lot of um professors lying around in
academ who could do this research all
you need is to subsidize so for instance
like like the center of fire safety as a
compute cluster we'd love to expand it
um we're only able to support not not
that many um professors to do uh
research with large language models and
very compute intensive experiments but
there are a lot of a lot of professors
who um uh could be doing more research
here so I think that probably there
aren't that many people working at these
organizations I should say as well and
uh so I wouldn't I wouldn't bet on them
um to fix everything you're actually
just correlating it with like what is
Jared coplan's safety Vision what is Yan
Le's safety vision and like you're
you're exp you're getting like two or
three bets if you were like giving you
know each of them money and I think
that's not a very Diversified portfolio
and you should expect blind spots just
because uh people aren't don't have
can't simulate a collective intelligence
a broad research effort um by themselves
even if they work very hard and have
lots of discussions and are you know
take out have good deference to outside
views and so on they just can't they
just can't simulate that function um so
I would suggest if one's wanting to
subsidize um Safety Research we can if
there's can have subsidize like a
compute cluster then we can have high
accountability of like you're not
allowed to run this project because this
doesn't seem sufficiently safety related
um instead of giving like money no
strings attached to some academics and
they run off with it um so that would be
my uh preferred intervention um and I
think that there's uh it can take orders
of magnitude more so like if any of them
are listening you like reach out to us
I'd love to give more compute to uh to
um uh people do relevant uh doing
relevant research on on safety in a in a
nice Diversified portfolio across
transparency and adversary robustness
and back doors in machine learning
models uh uh and unlearning um uh these
types of topics do you think some safety
breakthroughs uh would be kept secret
say say a safety breakthrough at at
Google deepmind made the AI useful or in
in a way that that incentivized them not
to share the safety breakthrough or do
what do you expect
safety breakthroughs to be shared widely
as as if they were found in in an
academic lab I think for Market
positioning one of them could occupy the
niche of being the safest of the racing
companies we are technically the safest
um so I think that's um currently
occupied by anthropic and this might
make it fairly useful when pitching
themselves for say a defense contract
that look weird the more reliable
organiz ation um compared to our
competitors and so if they would be
open- sourcing some of that then I think
they would lose um a some of that
competitive Advantage so it's quite
conceivable that um they'd hold on to um
hold on to things I mean there's many
safety projects they do for which the
code is not like open source uh so we
see that to some extent there but I I
think it can make sense for uh one of
them to try and just be a bit safer than
the others or a bit more reliable than
the others yeah I I've heard Sam Alman
that the CEO of of open AI talk about
releasing these systems so specifically
releasing gbt 3 and and four to the
world chat gbt in order to gather more
attention to the issue do do you think
this is a viable
strategy is this too risky or or is it
worth trying I think um to answer a more
extreme question to possibly get a sense
of my position on this I think the
release of llama 2 for instance by meta
which is an open source large language
model around the capacity of GPT 3.5 I
think the the um benefits of that
actually outweigh the costs um uh it
enables a lot more research um it also
improves our defenses um uh against some
of the immediate applications of these
AI systems so for instance um it came
out today that North Korea is using some
of these AI systems I don't know whether
it's llama 2 that'd be my guess because
it's just among it's the most capable
open source system or or code
potentially using AI systems to identify
vulnerabilities in software and then
that helps them short list things to to
attack this isn't an extremely capable
uh or this doesn't you know rewrite the
cost benefit analysis of cyber attacks
it doesn't um rupture our digital
ecosystem um but this basically gives us
some um preview enforces um these these
issues on um people's is attention uh so
um I I think there's I think there's an
argument to be made for um
open sourcing llama two or if it's
trained on 10x more compute llama 3 um
after that there's more uncertainty um
uh we'd have to see uh because maybe it
could be repurposed for things like
bioweapons then or it would be
substantially more capable at hacking
and scamming things like that I I think
there's uh a real argument to be made
for um some short-term stressors sort of
snapping the system into um to do
something about it or at least waking
them up
uh but I think systems function better
with some amount of stressors when the
stressors get too extreme then it can
undermine the system so it's complicated
I'm I I think maybe the the situation
the case of opening ey releasing these
things or how they want to go about
release strategies I would not surprise
me if that uh should change or if would
be better to do other things uh in the
future yeah do you know something about
the internal processes for deciding when
to release these models so in the case
of like meta for instance uh may have
like a chief legal officer um vote on
whether or potentially a veto power that
could still be overwritten by the CEO
which may have happened in the case of
llama 2 um um being suggestive here
because I haven't heard a second source
for it but um usually for decisions
though um like you know open AI will be
accountable to their board um the board
I don't know whether they have formal
powers to decide whether they'd be
voting um often boards have blunt powers
of just firing the ceoo um and uh there
often aren't processes in place for
these um larger scale decisions uh so
you could imagine a CEO just deciding
unilaterally to have something uh
released um uh and that's something that
organizational safety could improve
would be processes for high stakes
decisions as an example but yeah but by
default boards do not have um fering uh
uh control and so it's often up to the
the CEO um to to make the the call so
you have a single point to failure what
is the Swiss Cheese model of
organizational safety yeah so I'm I'm
mentioning and if people are wanting to
hear more about uh the organizational
safety
literature um we'll have the AI safety
ethics and Society textbook uh out in
November and one of the chapters would
be on safety engineering um the Swiss
Chiefs model is is a uh easy to
communicate it's it's a it's kind of
outdated but it gets at a um just like
how people are doing X risk analysis of
existential risk from mayi earlier they
have a toy model that captured some of
the and some of the scenarios to be
concerned about but it's important not
to let that be the lens by which you
filter everything through that's that
captures some of it but not all of it
and the the Swiss cheese one captures
some of the Dynamics but not all the
Dynamics but anyway the Swiss chees
model with that with with that prel side
essentially having multiple layers of
Defense if you have red teeming um even
red teing for a catastrophic risk that
reduces your the risk of catastrophe but
it's not itself perfect uh you might
might also want stronger informational
security too to make sure that if you
had a dangerous model that it doesn't
leak um you could have um you could have
better transparency tools to check for
deceptive behavior in AI systems but if
those transparency tools failed maybe
you would want monitoring of these AI
systems so that uh before they take any
action it needs to be approved by a
something equivalent to like an
artificial conscience or filter um that
would filter out some of the immoral
actions of AI agents before they're able
to take them and so all of these
together can increase the reliability of
the system so there isn't a um that the
hope is that if you stack together many
of these you've substantially reduced
your risk uh this isn't looking for a
perfect airtight solution this is
looking for layering on many different
defenses uh to actually reduce risk so
if I wanted to reduce bio risk for
inance here's an example um of of a
Swiss cheese thing first I could um
first there' be the diffuse thing maybe
there could be some regulation about you
know not allowing models with these
capabilities but let's say I'm a an
organization that takes safety more
seriously so that depends on safety
culture so that's some sort of like
barrier um regulation might be some
barrier against this risk safety culture
might be some barrier against this risk
so then they have enough of a safety
culture they're willing to add a lot of
these safety features now these safety
features themselves will end up posing
or end up having lots of different
layers of Defense you could have an
input filter to try and remove um
whether there's a request to create a
bioweapon you could also remove veraly
related data from the pre-training
distribution so that it likely knows a
lot less about rology you could have an
output filter as well um which would
even if somebody jailbreaks the input
filter then they're also going to need
to jailbreak the output filter which
makes which is harder to do and you
could imagine adversar training this as
well so that' be another layer uh so
that it would be more robust to people
trying to jailbreak those those layers
of Defense but then you also have um
there's also people who could through
the API fine-tune the model and inject
some of that bio knowledge back into the
model so you could have a
filter that screens the the fine-tuning
data um so that that information can't
get back into the the weights and then
you could add another layer which would
be an unlearning layer where you would
assume that before you hand back the
fine-tuned model to the user before they
get it back we're going to run a
scrubbing unlearning knowledge expunging
thing to expunge some of any bio
knowledge if there is any and that would
be yet another layer this approach
reduces the risk of some bio catastrophe
are any of those airtight no um but do
they work better collectively absolutely
so this is why we shouldn't be focusing
on these like airtight Solutions uh
exclusively we also need to make use of
these various uh uh layers of Defense um
that's how we actually reduce the
probability of of existential risk um we
can't let infection be the enemy of the
good if we'd say well if we can't build
a a completely 100% reliable input
filter then we shouldn't have an input
filter or we that's a dead end so we
shouldn't investigate it that's just not
that that's just not how things work so
H tell us more about the textbook I'm
I'm pretty excited to read this uh I I
hope that this this is a product that
should exist I think specifically tell
us more about how how do you think about
updating this or keeping it up to date I
think for for a textbook on AI safety it
won't probably work if the next version
is um out in uh
2034 or something like that right so so
how do you how do you keep it up to date
and and also you can just present the
textbook which I think listeners will be
interested in I mean I since I've been
around in in in academ for a while I do
have um at least some of a sense of like
what things what content is more likely
to stand the test of time so that one's
not talking about um you know Dolly 2 or
something which is already outdated um
uh or like what are kind of like fad
topics and uh not not um giving those
too much um not giving those um air time
I mean an example of this would be like
an unsolved problems in L sa I don't
know two three years ago or something
but there we introduced um emergent
capabilities which I think has um become
uh fairly popular before um Burns at
alls paper on honesty and whatnot where
also honesty is a big part of of
alignment so there's sometimes one needs
to call shots too as to what things will
even if there aren't isn't much of a
literature on it at all uh need to um
predict what will end up standing the
test of time but I so I think it should
have some reasonable longevity because
we're not focusing on transient
knowledge but instead like
General interdisciplinary Frameworks for
thinking about risk across all these
sectors because we had this issue of
like there's in if you're thinking about
AI risk you have to think a bit about um
geopolitics you have to think about
international relations to some extent
you think about AI risk you have to
think about corporate governance and AI
developers and what sort of incentives
are driving them um you have to think
about the individual AI systems
themselves too you have to think about
organizational safety you have to think
about broad variety of of um factors uh
and we'll basically Focus quite a bit on
on Frameworks for thinking um uh clearly
about each of those um I would imagine
that later one could have you know GPT 6
like help like update the the textbook
anyway uh so honestly is actually like
the the plan for it so some something in
that direction how technical is is the
book this is it contain pseudo code like
a like a standard AI textbook the
premise of it is to onboard people from
different disciplines this isn't written
for machine learning PhD people there
are lots of different fields economists
legal Scholars philosophers um people
without technical backgrounds policy
makers um Think Tank people who want
more of a a systematic understanding of
these issues and um so it's it's largely
written for people without any specific
background uh and it's not trying to be
a um sort of like a introductory machine
learning PhD course that would be the
course. MLS safety.org if you want a a a
course of various technical topics or
the machine learning safety course um
but this one is more um uh focusing on
you know the the as we were discussing
the the game theory of this the various
governance Solutions conceptually uh
many of the you know um arguments
associated with Rog gay eyes why might
they be power why might they be
deceptive um understanding that there's
also introduction to machine learning
and reinforcement learning in it uh
understanding Collective action problems
since that was fairly relevant and um
these uh uh competitive pressures uh
there's also ethics in the uh book as
well where if you're assuming that
you've got your AI systems to be
somewhat reliable then we have to start
worrying about making it beneficial and
um think so there's uh uh various um
bits of uh AI ethics as well of what um
objectives that we might give the AI
system what would those look like what
would be some of the you know moral
trade-offs that you're making there but
um so it's covering um uh AI safety
ethics and Society um so uh trying to um
be um fairly broad you should have uh
Lexus slides uh and presumably um I'll
get around to recording videos for it
too the goals there's several goals of
it like to compress the content right
now if you want to understand AI risk
basically need to be like part of like
an intellectual scene like in the Bay
Area probably maybe in maybe somewhat in
Oxford um so very high barriers to entry
um and then if you do you're probably
going to take a somewhat Nero view just
because you're they're all interested in
Rogue AI um and don't have like as much
interaction with like the the rest of
the world as so you'll have many blind
spots um uh as to um a lot of the the
social variables and the broader soot
technical problem the knowledge has been
a bit diffused across various different
blocks and uh to to stay up to date
you've you've often had to jump around
from different places so it it would be
nice to have something that's more
compressed uh so some of the goals are
to like reduce the fragmentation of AI
risk knowledge increase the readability
and the the sort of compression rate of
this content and so there's reducing the
barrier to entry to these these crucial
ideas this should hopefully scale the
number of people who understand AI risk
extremely quickly I I was somewhat
surprised by although though there's a
lot of global attention the number of
like new experts flooding in has been um
I think very underwhelming is is that
good or bad sometimes it's it's a bad
thing if experts are are rushing into
the to the new newly you know hot uh
idea I think that if people are
onboarded well and have a more um
comprehensive understanding if they're
basically like charlatans who aren't
going to like do their their work then
that's more of a problem so I think by
default with like another capabilities
jumper or two they will flood in there's
basically a question and I don't
anticipate they're going to read lots of
you know less wrong.com posts um uh to
be on board they're just going to start
talking and trying to make be about
themselves um I I say this this as in in
in my time empirical machine learning
research it basically should assume that
when some area starts getting pretty hot
there'll be lots of random new people
coming in um and trying to to influence
the discussion substantially uh
hopefully the people as they come in
would have some understanding of many of
the the basics though but I think by
default it's relatively inaccessible
we'll have to read a lot of scattered
content uh um from different places and
a lot of it'll be idiosyncratic and
it'll just take a long time to go
through those are some of the the
reasons for um for uh doing this and
then and then also I think that given
that Rog a eyes is not the only concern
um or only risk Source there's a lot of
content that even a lot of people who've
been thinking about AI risk for a while
will possibly need to come uh become
aware of um uh so um that's why so just
as a grad Jud student what I just sort
of like developed and just uh focused on
these these other things other than
Rogue AI um uh and then now I think
people are recognizing the importance of
that so now they'll hopefully be or so
now there'll be um some um some material
to um help getting more uh formal
understanding of these other sorts of uh
of these other sorts of issues that's
great I'm I'm looking forward to reading
it I think we should we should
nonetheless talk about Rogue AI That's
that's your last category of risk one
issue here is proxy gaming how does that
work how is it dangerous yeah so you
could imagine if you've got a very
powerful AI system if it finds
reliability holes in the objective that
it's given then this could be uh
destructive because it's being Guided by
a flawed objective I think an ex a
colloquial example is with um I believe
in Hanoi there'd be in um a bounty for
killing rats and so if you give rats you
get a bounty but then uh people were
incentivized to breed rats uh so as to
collect more of that Bounty that would
be an example of an objective that you
put forward that ends up getting gain
it's fairly difficult to encode um all
of your values like wellbeing and
whatnot into um a specific objective a
simple uh a simple objective uh so you
might expect some approximation to what
you actually care about in in machine
learning a a famous example this is the
boat racing or Coast Runners example
that open AI had which was um of proxy
gaming of there's a there's a reward
function and the reinforcement learning
agent would optimize that reward
function it was this was a racing game
you'd think it would um optimize the
reward function by going around the
track but what it instead learned to do
was it can get a higher reward by
getting lots of Turbo boosts and um the
turbo boosts it could get very um Su
rapid sequence of them by S crashing
into walls and catching on fire and then
um continually turbo boosting uh in that
way and that would help it get a higher
score uh so there are often holes in
these objectives um uh due to an ability
to compute exactly the the right
objective or um or maybe we can only
monitor some parts of the system there's
there computational and spatial and
temporal constraints on the quality of
the objective meaning that you're going
to often have to go with an
approximation so something perfectly
ideal this relates to good heart's law
which works in in kind of human domains
also in which it's difficult to to
specify exactly what it is you want and
whenever you specify something you want
uh that thing you've specified is now
open to being gamed so uh an example
here might be that you want deep
scientific insight and you you assume
that that such Insight correlates with
citations or number of citations but
then you get gaming of of the citation
systems in which academics are
incentivized to maximize citations at
the cost of scientific Insight so it is
this a more General problem across all
agents um humans included yeah yeah I
don't think this is specific to um I
don't think this is specific to AI
agents um I I will say that some
objectives are harder to gain than
others for instance the the bounty on
rat tails is a lot easier to game than
like citations because you know
citations can be very valuable for
getting you know immigr becoming getting
a green card for instance and it's a
strong strong incentives to do it and uh
um uh but um uh it's it's it's
nonetheless challenging there so some of
these objectives even when people are
trying very hard to gain it they still
can be correlated with um a lot like
college admissions still focuses
incentivizes people to be productive yes
they'll go overboard in you know
studying for the exams and whatnot the
the college admissions tests yes they'll
go overboard in the number of
extracurriculars and what not but I
still think it like does can help shape
compared to there not being the
incentive first place I think overall my
take on good heart's law is that that
there's some objectives that are or some
goals are all goals and proxies are
wrong some are useful and some though
when gained in particular ways could be
potentially catastrophic um so there's
there's quite a variety um there there
are some objectives as well that people
would claim would uh produce good
outcomes for instance if you gave an AI
an objective like make the world the
best place it can and if that was
actually the objective you gave it okay
um that's quite different from like make
people um very engaged in this with this
you know this this product uh that
that's quite different um I think that
making these um proxies incorporate more
of our values becomes more possible
across time because the systems can
represent these other sorts of Notions
of say well-being of autonomy uh because
they um uh have a lot better of a world
model and more of an understanding of of
people as well um however so I I think
that getting um objectives that are in
the right direction seem possible the
issue is making them be robust to
adversarial pressure I'm not as
concerned about like we get telling ai
go cure cancer and then it does
something like oh I'll give lots of
people cancer to experiment on them to
speed up the experimentation process
this is easily ruled out by some like
objective with like an interpret the
request as a reasonable reasonable
person would this is this is a new a
fairly new development in AI that we now
have these large language models that
that can at least to some extent
understand common sense and have kind of
a a more
subtle understanding of of human values
yeah earlier there'd be the AIS are um
uh they would be kind of like savants
where they they understand some
particular thing well but then nothing
else and you know human values are so
late in The evolutionary process that
suggest that they're very um late be one
of the last things that AI learn um but
uh that fortunately wasn't the case we
explored this a few years ago in the um
in the the paper with the the ethics
data set we're basically using that to
show that look they've got understanding
of various morally Salient
considerations here's their predictive
performance on like well-being things
here's their understanding of of
deontological rules and uh Notions in
Justice and fairness such as um whether
people get what they deserve or whether
people are being impartial um uh so they
they have a a an understanding of a lot
of um morally Salient considerations
there is a question of reliability
though if they're optim in that
objective are they basically is that
objective succumbing to that adversarial
optimization pressure if it's optimizing
it it's basically functionally similar
to it being adversarial to that
objective this is why there's a focus on
adversarial robustness because later we
would have we've got an AI agent that's
optim that's it's given a goal and this
this AI system is outputting whether
it's succeeding by the goal or not so
we've got an AI evaluator and we've got
an AI system that's optimized ni go this
AI evaluator you don't want that being
gamed you want that AI evaluator being
adversar robust robust to optimizers
trying to um uh say that it's doing a
good job so that's the sort of threat
model later stage and that's how some of
these topics that were explored and
vision and whatnot um end up and now
finally um with the large language
models tax paper which you can I guess
read about that you know the the New
York Times um where you can Jailbreak
and manipulate these models with little
ad seral suffixes um in in a later stage
we'd have ai systems evaluating other AI
systems and you want and those AI
systems that are evaluating or
implicitly encoding an objective and you
want those to be adversarially robust uh
so adversar robustness is not a easy
problem to fix and if you don't fix that
issue then you might have some AI
systems just gaming the system and going
off doing a um optimizing an objective
aggressively um that is not what we want
is there a problem here with the concept
of maximization
so it seems to me that it would be less
dangerous to tell an AI system go go
earn a million dollars on the stock
market than to tell it Go earn as much
money as possible on the stock market
could we could we kind of cap the the
impact and the potential negative impact
by by capping the the goal also uh I I
think that's that's one approach could
you could imagine conceptually a variety
you could have satisficers where they
basically are like and now I'm good to
go I I don't need to keep optimizing
this aggressive there is the possibility
of um you know not giving them
open-ended goals or very ambitious goals
um would would make them um less
concerning more constrained ones but um
there's uh adversary robustness would be
one there's also be anomaly detection
detecting um anomaly
detection is something that's researched
quite a bit in Vision I've had some part
in trying to um have have the research
Community focus on that uh and and I
imagine anomaly detection will be very
relevant again when we're trying to
monitor the activities of various AI
agents are they doing something
suspicious here um while they're being
monitored are they you know kind of
adversarially trying to make the monitor
think oh it's it's doing the right thing
so we'll need anomaly detection too to
detect if there's some um proxy uh being
gained that can reduce our exposure to
to to that risk um there's there's also
having some held out um objectives uh of
which the agent is unaware
um that it's being evaluated against um
and that can also do things like reduce
the the risk of it um being going to
extreme um and optimizing the
idiosyncrasies of the evaluator uh but
uh this this is a a problem I think that
most of the problem right now though if
we if we have large language models try
and optimize a reward model that judges
them uh they can do that and they
eventually start to over optimize it um
although the optimizers that are much
more effective at breaking machine
learning models are actually just
straight up adversarial attacks compared
to uh compared to neural models that are
taking multiple steps and um iterating
on their their outputs the the generic
gradient-based aers oil taxs are just
much more effective so I think of this
sort of risks of of of gaming I think
most uh we need to do more just to
address the the typical osere robustness
issue gold drift is a somewhat related
issue uh where the ai's goals shift over
time and the AI might come to take an
instrumental goal as an intrinsic goal
how could this happen uh it's still a
bit unclear to to me how an an
instrumental goal would become intrinsic
over time so to to start out with an
intrinsic goal is something that you
care about for itself that could be
something like uh uh happiness or
pleasure uh for some others that could
say you know maybe friendship you'd say
I care about that in itself s you might
care about your partner's well-being not
because it's useful to you but you care
about their well-being uh in in itself
and then there are other things that are
just instrumental for achieving those
intrinsic Goods such as like money um
money lets you buy things so that you
could have higher well-being or a car it
gets you from point A to point B however
some people have intrinsi um to use a
sort of uh more bostrum phrase um uh
intrinsi um some of these instrument
goal some people actually just directly
want money uh even to a point where it
doesn't make sense um or power um many
people are just like they want Power um
even if it like harms other parts of
their like well-being um they're they're
willing to make that type of trade-off
uh so these these uh they might latch
onto these cues and um develop some of
the wrong associations so we see that in
people and there's there's a risk that
AI systems might develop those those
wrong cues as well um gold drift could
happen in some other types of way too
where if you have um multiple different
agents they might interact in some
unexpected way and then a new goal
becomes a new goal starts to drive their
behavior uh an example we've we can see
this in basic AI multi-agent situations
it's not catastrophic of course because
we're still here but um in in some AI
Society in some Stanford paper from
earlier this year the AI start talking
with each other and then they start
arranging um uh social structures that
they're going to have a they're going to
throw an event uh at some person's house
then and then this starts to then they
start acting in in all these ways to
make sure this type of thing happen and
then the these sorts of things start to
be what drives their behavior there's
some other way in which things can can
um end up drifting not necessarily
through having something be intrinsic
but there could be these emergent goals
from interactions that end up driving
behavior certainly um there are many
emergent things in society things that
become new and this isn't the goal that
I originally had when I was you know 10
years old but now this is some of these
things end up driving my Behavior quite
substantially so if we have adaptive AI
systems and if they end up responding to
each other uh then you could have some
emergent complexity um happen and that
that those interactions that that
behavior starts driving the the overall
group Behavior as they're imitating each
other as they're responding to each
other and um uh uh so it's basically
multi-agent systems be very difficult to
control in the single agent one you'd
have to worry about there being some
wrong association between an intrinsic
and instrumental goal like money or
power um uh and that could mean if that
does happen if if if basically something
wrong gets intrinsi then you're in a
very dangerous situation because then
your AI has a goal um that's just
different from what you wanted and so
then it will to get that goal it will
optimize against you it will respond
adversarially it will resist your
efforts to shut it down um so that it
can achieve that goal so although it's
not you know something that necessarily
happens by default or with extremely
high probability if it does happen then
you got a substantial tail risk um uh in
front of you I wonder whether these AIS
will persist for long enough for gold
drift to happen so normally we retrain
models every couple of years we we
switch out for the newest ones uh and so
it's not like a person that that has 30
years to change the their values will
they last long enough for gold drift to
to to matter so I guess two things um
one is the world will move substantially
more quickly in the future um such I
like in often in in these more pivotal
periods I I don't know if it was Lenin
or something like that like there are
decades in which weeks happen and then
there are weeks in which like decades
happen so um even if there is a high
replacement rate in the AI population
this goes on you know a much slower
process they could still end up
constructing um things that end up
causing their goals to be different like
they let's say they develop some
different type of social infrastructure
for mediating their interactions um
there are new AI companies being formed
and they're end up driving many of them
then those um features of the
environment would end up affecting the
generation that comes after it um so you
could still imagine some type of drift
um some intergenerational Drift But if
each generation is very short you could
still imagine some some type of gold
drift in that way this is kind of um
think think of yourself many of the
goals the intrinsic goals that you have
intrinsic desires that you have are
completely unlike those when you were
younger the even tast in food um the
things you care about maybe you acquired
Sports you're you're you're tast in
music um uh affiliations um all of these
things end up changing across time and
so and they can also go away too some of
the intrinsic things you care about like
I care about this person's well-being
for themselves but then you break up
with them oh now now I actually don't
care about their well-being in itself um
uh they I don't have that strong of a
feeling toward them so um adaptive
systems carry this this type of this
type of property uh this is this is one
way in which um uh they end up gaining
some goals that we didn't intend either
through some emergent intera goal from
the product of various interactions or
through them
intrinsyx with that and reward and then
just end up seeking the the the power
itself could could gold drift be a good
thing so we we wouldn't want to to fix
human values from from the year 1800 for
example you could describe our our
changing goals from from back then to
now as a form of goal drift where where
people from 1800 might disagree
violently with with whatever we believe
now but we we still probably think it's
it's a good thing that we've changed our
values yeah could it be good and could
we learn from from the AIS yeah so I
think this is this is a a good point in
what makes thinking about AI risk
generally a lot harder as we mentioned
earlier there's this balance issue uh
with malicious use that because you'd be
concerned about unilateralist misusing
AIS or Rogue actors misusing AI is that
we should then centralize power but then
you end up getting some other
existential risk of of lack in of
concentration of power and then I think
likewise in this case too there you
can't have a society in complete stasis
um and as would be driven by new
emergent type of structures uh you
should still try and make sure that you
have some control over that process or
reasonable control over that that that
process it seems if there's not much
control then I think it's likely to slip
uh uh from your hands but otherwise uh
so there's basically one will have to
strike a a balance between um some very
chaotic state where they're running wild
and some stasis uh and this is just a
continual issue in in um uh many areas
of of uh of um of evolving groups um
yeah that would also be a problem of if
there'd be too much entrenchment if
there isn't an ability to have
adaptation of the things that we care
about yeah so anyway that's there's some
dissonance there aren't simple answers
with this this is why this will be a
balancing act um and uh um this also why
I don't expect a in particular a single
solution to solve everything for all
time we'll need to respond we'll need
institutions and structures and control
measures that respond to the um uh
features of the environment and
calibrate accordingly why could AIS
become power seeking so this this is
this is a very um uh I think one of the
the main sort of AI risk story would be
it becomes it becomes power seeking I'll
uh uh make a bit of a case for it and
I'll speak about some some issues with
it too um you could imagine a person
gives an AI system a goal like go make
me a lot of money as an instrumental
goal gaining a lot of power seems like a
very helpful way to accomplish that that
um higher level goal so there's a
concern that when you specify a goal
that there'll be some subg goals that
are too too correspond too correlated
with power and um you'd want to make
sure that you can control um that those
those Tendencies so that's one of just
being when you're just directly giving
an AI a goal it may have a goal that's
correlated with power but that's that's
not is that terribly unexpected uh the
main we will give them goals that relate
to power quite a bit militaries will
probably build AI systems that are
fairly power seeking um uh and so we we
should expect some amount of AIS that
are pursuing uh Power um uh either as
their or as their main goal or as one of
their main sub goals and and and maybe
maybe power seeking to limited extent is
okay basic feature of of of
accomplishing many of these these sorts
of goals like for instance like the the
fetch the coffee one it would have a if
you instructed to fetch the coffee it
would have an incentive to preserve
itself because it can't fetch the coffee
otherwise and but you might want to
curtail some of those Tendencies so that
those don't get out of hand but that
would be a you know we we've had a paper
at icml earlier this year um where we're
deliberately giving it penalties to
penalize some of these these um
tendencies that it has when it is trying
to seek its reward it starts um having
incentives to um acrw resources and and
and things like that and then can we
have it more uh acquire the resources
that are more minimal to accomplishing
its goals can we have it engage in less
power seeking Behavior so I think that
that's something that we can offset but
we'll need to make sure that we have
good control measures uh uh for that to
keep that keep that in check there's
also the um so one of just people
directly instructing it with goals that
are by default probably going to be
pretty related to power there's also
maybe they would
intrinsically care let's say that they
had some random goal it's like a
paperclip maximizer you're you're
sampling from use old verbage you're
sampling from mind space and that has a
random set of desires and whatever that
set of desires then it would end up
trying to seek a substantial amount to
power that's um one claim um uh but I
think that has to be some more
rigorously argued I I should claim that
I would like to note that I think that a
lot of those power seeking arguments
there's there's um I don't think it
works as well as I thought it did the
the the arguments associated with them I
still think it's a relevant thing that
we'll want to control the the subg goals
um of of AI systems make sure they're
not not uh um too strongly related to
power and um that there's nothing
unexpected going on there so for
instance people might argue for power
seeking by saying like well power is
instrumentally useful for a broad
variety of goals therefore it will seek
power if it's trying to accomplish any
sort of reasonable goal and you'd ask
them what power is and then they'd say
power is what's instrumentally useful
for accomplishing a wide variety of
goals and go okay well that's a topology
so we need to be more careful what
exactly are we meaning by power here um
separately there's often a bit of so
that that's one like slight like bug
that lurks in the background is that
they'll Define power in terms of
instrumental stuff and then it it's
tological another issue is that there's
sometimes a conflation between power
seeking and dominance seeking those are
not the same thing uh when the AI is
trying to fetch the coffee um and is
engaging in self-preservation to do so
it's not necessarily therefore trying to
take over the world uh so saying that an
AI is power seeking is not necessarily
existential indeed you could imagine
various ways in which um other powerful
actors engage in power seeking Behavior
but don't try and seek dominance so for
instance different countries in trying
to increase their own power to preserve
themselves this is the sort of thesis of
neorealism or structural realism and
what happens is they will basically many
states will just try and keep power
relative to many of their peers if
Germany for instance tries to take it's
it's seeking power to protect itself but
if it tries seeking power at the level
of a global domination it will be met
with force uh there will be balancing
from other peers so when we're in a
multi-agent situation then it doesn't
necessarily always make sense for AI
systems to try and take over the world
because there'll be other AI agents
would be that will thwart my preferences
or goals and desires so I will
counteract you balancing in
international relations is what this is
called that's a thing that could offset
dominant seeking so it's not necessarily
the case that power seeking is is
dominant seeking and trying to take over
the world an additional point is that we
can partly influence the dispositions of
AI systems sorry to say we can do that
we can make these like have dispositions
to be a good chatbot um or be a good
assistant uh now how strong is that it's
not perfect but if it were given a task
like hey go um uh accomplish this this
go accomplish some goal for me if it
would think well you know the best way
would be I could accomplish this goal
better if I um uh uh were extremely
powerful and took over the world but
that may not be in keeping with its
values uh necessarily there so it may
have some tendency pulling in that
direction but you could also give it
some dispositions to pull it against it
and that might be sufficient to offset
some of these Tendencies toward power um
even if there is some incentive there it
may not be enough to overwhelm it so a
lot of this discussion about
instrumental convergence needs to think
about the the balance between um balance
between these uh these forces and they
would need to argue basically that the
instrumental Drive is extremely strong
to overwhelm fine tuning and all these
sorts of things uh which I don't think
that there's much of a specific argument
for for that I want to highlight here uh
Joe Carl Smith has a great report I
think the most rigorous argument for why
power seeking in AI could be
existentially dangerous so just for
listeners who are interested in in what
I think is the best argument for for
that uh out there I agree I agree um uh
he helped uh popularize the the sort of
power seeking phrase as well and I think
that by focusing on power that helped us
integrate this into some other like
academic discussions like power versus
cooperation what I was describing here
just a moment ago about balancing was
that we can you know take a cue from the
uh international relations literature of
seeing like well power seeking agents
when that's one of their their main
goals don't necessarily that doesn't
necessarily turn into them trying to
seek domination uh another thing is that
in Bostrom in superintelligence there's
also a part slight of hand not not
intentional but I suppose maybe an
accident where he's saying that power
makes you better able to accomplish your
goals therefore they will seek power
that's saying that something is helpful
if you have it that doesn't mean that
it's rational to seek it so although
there's an incentive for it that doesn't
mean it's instrumentally rational to
pursue it so for instance it would we if
we run the argument in a different way
it would be helpful for me to be a
billionaire that doesn't mean that it's
rational for me to try to become a
billionaire uh I could in that would
carry a lot of risks that would take a
lot of time um the existence of
incentives aren't necessarily enough to
say that that's what will be driving
their behavior um or is the first
approximation of their behavior uh and I
think that there are um other ways in
which just power seeking doesn't emerge
um or dominant seeking doesn't emerge if
you give it some goals like obviously if
you say you know shut yourself off or if
you give it a goal like don't seek power
um uh these are obvious like counter
examples for that just to show that this
isn't like a you know it's not a law of
all AI systems that they will try and
seek power separately if you give it a
more goal like go fetch the mil it could
try and take over the military to put up
a you know a a motorcade to make sure
that they can get to the the store very
quickly but you know if you had some
time penalty or something this would not
necessarily be the the thing to uh thing
to do so um instead just go fetch the
milk would often be the best way of
getting the reward instead of some very
circuitous path uh now so I I do think
that there is a risk of if you have ai
agents that are not protected and
autonomous you could get power seeking
type behavior for the same reason that
states try to shore up their power um
they Shore up their power because there
isn't anybody they can call on for help
if they're getting attacked necessarily
like if the US starts getting attacked
you know maybe some countries will come
but there isn't a police force that will
settle the issue um so there the best
they can do is try to short up power to
defend themselves so that they can't be
pushed around like that so we have a
non-h hierarchical or quote unquote
anarchic International system and that
incentivizes agents to seek power to
preserve themselves to pursue whatever
their goals are and you could imagine if
AI systems are not protected if they um
are part of say some crime syndicate or
if they're Rogue they're Unleashed
somebody unleashes them then those
systems would actually have a very
strong instrumental incentive to seek
power in the same way that states do
that if they want to protect themselves
um from some potential adversaries that
can harm them uh there isn't somebody to
call on they can't ask the US go if
there are crimes in they can't say US
government protect me I'm getting harmed
that that's not a possibility to them so
what they have to do is they have to
take matters in their own hands and
accumulate their own power so so what
I've done is I've sort of flipped things
a bit there'd be the usual argument that
AI might be power seeking just by their
inherent Nature by the inherent Natures
of goals and optimizers and things like
that but I've instead mentioned that one
source of power seeking is humans give
them some sort of goals that are very
correlated with power and then there
might be some unexpected stuff that
happens in their sub goals and then the
other thing I've done is I've mentioned
how the structure of the environment
that they're in some structural reasons
for why they might end up seeking power
too I'm not as sure about them having an
intrinsic one or internal reason for
power seeking but I think um goals being
given intentionally um or the structure
of the environment that they find
themselves in it's a sort of cage that
they're locked in there's really nothing
they can do if they're wanting to
accomplish their goals other than to
part invest a lot in protecting
themselves uh would also incentivize
them to to seek a substantial amount of
power um so I do think power seeking is
a concern but not for the same reasons
that other people are giving like we're
going to randomly sample a mind for mind
space it'll be very alien and but by way
of almost any desires it will uh
necessarily try to um uh seek dominance
over Humanity um but I still would be
concerned about power seeking a How
concerned are you about deception
arising in AIS I think that the
contribution of focusing on Deception
was useful because we now see that um
uh AIS have to some extent some
representation of morally Salient
considerations as you explore in the
paper lining I was shared human values
in I I clear maybe 2020 or something um
where we measure that and show that now
by now it's obvious because it's in chat
Bots uh people can ask it you know moral
questions but um they have some capacity
for that um and the deception part
focuses on maybe they're actually uh
they although they maybe understand the
goal they don't necessarily feel
inclined to pursue it so in Psychology
this is a distinction between cognitive
empathy and compassionate empathy
cognitive empathy Psychopaths have they
could understand and predict what people
will end up feeling uh in response to
various actions they have very good
predictive model of of people's uh uh
feelings and their emotions and what
they think would think what they think
is valuable meanwhile if they have
compassion and empathy that's when they
feel motivated to do things by it um and
um uh help um people realize those
values
so there's a distinction um uh that uh
they would have cognitive empathy but
not necessarily compassionate empathy
and so if they're deceptive they could
basically play along they could be like
yeah I'll um uh I don't actually care
about you but I'm gonna act like it to
get my goals accomplished as Psychopaths
do and and and here maybe maybe we
should mention here how how the how the
how the drive of deception arises from
from the way that we are doing U
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback or how it could arise from that
so in the in the um uh Maki icml paper
we saw instances of them doing deception
because it simply helps them accomplish
um their goals better by default uh so
many environments just incentivize the
type of behavior if they have some type
of misalign goal from us uh then um uh
then it' be they could buide their time
and wait to come to power to take a
quote unquote treacherous turn so it
could just be very strongly incentivized
by some type of training process like by
just seek more reward deception can
often be a good trick when you're
monitored you know behave nicely when
you're not monitored um switch your
behavior behave in a more Cutthroat way
that's how um a deceptive Behavior can
be a a concern uh or some mellion type
of behavior and uh and we we there are
instances of this you could imagine as
you more non agentic case with chat
botes if they're um being given human
feedback Maybe maybe they'd have an
incentive to say very agreeable answers
to people um things that they'd say oh
that sounds good to me um even though
it's if it's not necessarily true um so
that's how even you know chat Bots might
be incentivized to be in a somewhat
deceptive uh Direction but we can also
see this an agents just the often helps
them accomplish their goals also
chatbots uh might learn to to recognize
the the ways in which there's they're
they're telling bad lies let's say the
the obvious thing they're saying that
are false are penalized whereas the more
sophisticated ways they they might be
telling FAL falsehoods are are not
penalized yeah good yeah so this is um
gets it like in in a lot of like
repeated interactions and whatnot
deception often emerges in the evolution
paper from from the last time I was here
we we spoke about how um a deception can
often be and concealment of information
can often be an evolutionally stable
strategy and that there are many
instances of deception in the
environment so it's a fairly difficult
thing to um blot out when you try and
control for it you often end up
selecting for more deceptive Behavior at
the um same time um we do have progress
on this though where um we can in uh a
recent paper we uh submitted to or in a
recent paper we uploaded to Archive
called uh representation engineering a
top- down approach to uh AI transparency
there we have instances many instances
it's not that difficult to control by
manipulating the internals of the model
whether or not it's lying it has an
internal concept of what is accurate we
can find a truth direction we can add
you know take subtract the direction or
something of that sort and then that can
cause it to spit out um uh incorrect uh
text and we have other more
sophisticated control measures too but
we can manipulate internals to do that
so it's within the capacity of AI
systems to to lie and be deceptive we
have another paper on that called uh uh
if you search AI deception and then may
be my like name or something then you'd
see that paper so many instances of AI
deception already um but we do have some
traction on this problem so fortunately
um there'd still be the issue of having
you know more reliable lie detectors and
being able to control them to be more
honest or output their true beliefs so
um there's there's definitely much more
work to be done but we're at least not
helpless um we don't need to wait um
another 30 years for interpretability
research to get to a state of being able
to just start to brush against the
question we now have some ability to to
influence whether AI Lie by controlling
their internals um uh and so that makes
me more optimistic about dealing with um
uh this this this problem but um uh you
know you don't want to do premature
celebration I don't know if how much
time we'll have to continue getting
those those uh detection measures and
those control measures to be highly
reliable uh so that'll depend on like
the the having a lot of researchers who
can research with these these Cutting
Edge very large models um to to make
progress on it yeah the the
representation engineering paper was was
super exciting uh maybe you could
explain what at what level does
representation engineering work because
it's it's different from mechanistic
interpretability it's more high level
and which is which is what we're after
in a sense we are we are after the the
high level emergent behavior in in these
models yeah I I was mentioning
compassionate empathy and cognitive
empathy because it's bed psychology but
I think trying to do something more like
a project like AI psychology or AI
cognitive science is I think what we
should be trying to do here so in the
case of this representation engine
that's I think we're trying to be the
analog of that where we're given these
high level representations of Truth and
goals and things like that can we make
it be so that it actually outputs its
beliefs um or what it says it believes
is actually what it believes for that
you need to have a handle on these very
high level Concepts um so that they're
not Psychopathic so that they actually
so that we can control their
dispositions to behave and have things
like compassion and empathy meanwhile I
think the mechanistic stuff is looking
at a much lower level it's looking more
at this the substrate at the neuron
level at the circuit level at the noet
to- node connection level um and that's
maybe closer to something like
neurobiology and but then what we're
doing is more like trying to study the
mind as opposed to trying to study the
specific structures in the brain and the
connections between them and how that
gives rise to phenomena so I think
philosophically I had tried many times
to do a paper on on transparency um uh
um historically but it did there wasn't
a good angle of attack um and um but uh
in my view it take too long um but I
think if we do it in a more top down
type of way where we try and here's the
eyes mil is try and decompose it into
some like f um representations that
drive a lot of its behavior and maybe
decompose those further and further
basically we have a big problem of
understanding an ai's mind let's break
it up into subcomponents and try and get
a handle on those and control those I
think that approach um might be more uh
efficient at um reducing risks of AI
deception then building from the bottom
up understanding you know this is how it
answers this is the circuit in it that
lets it understand multiple or identify
a multiple choice question and then this
helps it select the whether to outp put
the the full qu the full response back
or whether just to select A B C or D you
know things like that you can build
those up but that might become very uh
very complicated in time um so I think
it might make sense to not work from the
bottom up but um go from the uh the top
down there are analoges of this type of
approach in in cognitive science people
would initially try and just study
things at the synapse level but um it
can often be more fruitful of trying to
understand things at the at the
representational level what are the high
level emergent representations that are
a function of all the population of all
the neurons in the network and try and
try and understand things at that level
now there's there's of course a risk of
like well maybe maybe there's some funny
business that gave rise to that
representation and that that's true um
we could still do things to reduce that
risk by like trying to understand the
representations at various layers in the
network and um uh try and decompose the
system further and further so that there
isn't much um room for um funny business
or deception uh but uh so that's that's
it um uh at a um high level it's not
viewing neurons as the main unit of
analysis it's you viewing viewing
representation s is the main unit of of
analysis and neurons are relevant in so
far as they help us predict and explain
what's going on in representations but
those are more of a that's sort of just
the the substrate it's it's a comment on
the substrate in the same way that if we
have a computer program that plays go if
I'm reasoning about the go program I'm
just probably going to be thinking about
go strategies um when I'm playing
against it I don't need to think at the
software level like well where do you
think it what what um layer do you think
gets at right now or um uh what what
tensorflow um objective function did did
Alpha go end up optimizing here maybe
some of the example we don't need to
analy at that level we certainly don't
need to break it down at the level of
assembly we don't need to reason about
assembly to try and understand Its
Behavior so I think that there's um some
emerging complexity inside of neural
networks we just need to we can we can
study it at that level and it's studying
at that level is fruitful because
there's um an emergent ontology and some
coherent
structure inside of that which you end
up getting lost in the details when you
end up zooming in further to the to the
um uh to the neuron level so although
possible in principle it's possible in
principle to explain everything in terms
of it just like it's possible to explain
the economy in terms of particle physics
computationally you could do it but it
doesn't make sense to study it at that
level this isn't to say that they um
mechanistic interpretability and
representation engineering are
completely loose and separate there's
probably overlap just as like like in
biology um and chemistry they have some
overlap but you wouldn't try and
understand biology just Through
Chemistry and I think if you're trying
to understand representations I don't
think you're necessarily just going to
try and understand everything through
neurons and node to- node connections
and and specific execution Pathways and
treat it like a a uh computer program
but instead something uh something more
like a mind with um loose associational
high level
representations yeah so take it a a
cognitive tradeit like like honesty do
we know anything about how how that's
distributed across the model is it is it
is there like a center where in a
cluster uh of the weights in which this
is this is now representing honesty or
or functioning as as an as the honesty
module or is it more distributed across
the whole model yeah it the neural
network representations are highly
distributed which makes sort of trying
to bolt down and pinpoint specific
locations of a lot of functionality a
lot more difficult as well as the
interactions between all these
components too uh can end up giving rise
to a lot of complexity imagine that you
understood a neuron and it was this
detects a whisker at you know 27 degrees
and this other neuron you know detects
you know some an upper corner of a fire
hydrant and you can you can have you can
if you can understand these millions of
neurons that gets you some way but are
you really understanding the collective
overall emergent behavior of the system
uh that's that doesn't necessarily
follow so I don't think it's enough to
the lowest level parts to understand the
the overall system and its uh Collective
functioning but it can be helpful it can
provide some types of insights in the
case of honesty though I find that it's
a direction in its uh or its beliefs
about what's true or not are directions
in its representational space and it
doesn't seem to be located at a a uh
specific neuron so when we adjusting the
representations through various control
measures that we propose uh then then we
can actually end up manipulating it uh
so that anyway so partly this paper is
um a bit more like philosophical in like
what's the sort of Paradigm what's the
um how do we want to what's what's the
strategy that we're wanting to proceed
in making AI systems transparent the
representation level is the um going to
be a very fruitful way I should note
that um uh but but um it' be useful to
diversify over you know research agendas
and and things like that uh hopefully
we'll get more reliable control measures
and be able to modify relatively
arbitrary Parts which should we'll have
success when we can like inside of the
AI system when we have better ability to
sort of read their mind or um understand
the representations if we could use it
for like knowledge Discovery then we've
known that uh our our methods are fairly
good because they're probably going to
pick up some observations about the
world from their big pre-train
distribution that no individual knows or
that many individuals don't know and if
um so if we can get better um tools like
that then that would be a a late stage
sign of success yeah and it seems like
we have a better shot at success here
than than Neuroscience on humans because
we have such fine grained access to to
it's as if we had a human brain spre
spread out with full access to to what
all of the neurons are doing so so or do
you think that's right do you think we
have a better chance of success compared
to traditional Neuroscience yeah yeah
certainly I think the the sort of
mechanistic interpretability people
would claim this uh claim this as well
that um since we have access to the the
we have rewrite access to every
component of it um this allows for much
more controlled replicable experiments
and um substantial ability to do science
that uh the bare ears entry and
cognitive science um uh are many of them
are um removed there's also this might
get easier in time what makes this now
possible whereas previously it wasn't if
you use models like gpt2 or below they
just the representations are not very
good quite incoherent um but as we use
larger models like llama 2 um
pre-trained on many more tokens they
have some emergent internal structure
that actually starts to make some sense
um and directions that are correlated
with coherent Concepts that that humans
have I think earlier it's more like a
Shivali lith but now there since there
is some coherence to it it's not just a
big causal soup of connections uh so
this is why I think unfortunately this
wasn't something that we could have
particularly done um in like 2016 uh and
um is is very much something that's
possible now that previously wasn't Dan
thanks for spending so much time with us
here it's been very valuable for me and
I think it will be for our listeners too
great great great thank you for having
me have a good day